welcome to this video who talked on me
who talked on me from Japan was really
from to pen the sky the name and no name
yeah Japan has some doesn't have many um
many players in total and in the 90s
about ah all the seams I'm a really old
person in the 90s more than 15 years ago
I once played that number one of Japan
and this guy was um rated about 2,300 he
was very good at them I think Japanese
chess assume i'm not wrong this is this
shogi game this is Japanese chess and he
only played the Western um tab of chasm
gap as some sort of yeah recreational
side activity besides his studies of
Japanese chess I'm not sure how it is
nowadays but I don't think that Japan
has any of any gems form for instance
okay um we have on Moran variation on
sort of Moran with quincy too yeah this
is a theoretical position but this kind
of line is some it's difficult to to
play it is some always related to those
small moves like a 3h three and it's
hard to tell sometimes what those moves
are actually doing I'm trying to prevent
c5 here I'm not sure that this is really
a good plan but became I need to
find this over the board don't know the
theory okay he managed to play high if
the question is is he actually
threatening to play before I don't think
so but I need to yeah i mean ii for in
connection with bishop h2 but i need to
if i go here i cover this I'm not so
sure what my plan at this position is i
prevented c5 this is nice but it's not
so easy to determine how to proceed g6
is a curious move maybe night age 45 was
was indeed a possibility I came anyway
where do I go with this Bishop and what
is my my general ADM maybe it is an idea
to go out of the sea foam and go to be
three intending something like night g95
24 yeah 95 hit f3 something like that
could be an idea yeah okay let's do that
I'm not so sure about this c1 bishop
where do I want to go with this Bishop
is that should i go to d2 which I could
have done instead of queen bee three i
should i go to be to actually um and b2
was i know b 2 looks more natural to me
yeah maybe we should be two loops e1
something like that I know it takes this
is interesting this is interesting
should I take with the palm or should I
take with the night pawn would be the
automatic recaptcha to to keep his
bishop locked in on b7 but if I take
with the night the night is is nicely
placed on d4 and maybe um I can yeah not
sure it's it's not clear ok I take what
the night attack was the night we are
complicated very complicated at the
moment he cannot go see 5 because b5 is
detected so often gap here it's actually
possible that I'm threatening to take on
on b5 yeah he went out of all of this
tactical possibility ok Bishop where did
B to D 2 hmm yeah be too was was the
original idea he still cannot place he
fire ok develop this
yeah while my position looks nice it's
not so easy to determine how to make any
substantial progress let's cover cover
this a bit more and lady doesn't have a
bad position okay but the knight on d4
really prevents any it should be success
and moves like that hmm yeah now yeah
f4f why only has c4 but this is a good
square
hmm yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure at
all how to how to proceed
hmm try 93 to you for I really am really
unsure what to do yeah
hmm yeah curious through difficult to
come up with a constructive plan
you know i'm not sure that taking on b2
really was so great ah simple bishop age
29 f 2 yeah with 40 seconds on the clock
at jack yeah he sees this of course it's
it's even a mate it's even made him I
don't actually I think if I don't
blunder this I'm okay and don't think
that the taking on b2 was was a good
move yeah i'm probably not better but
I'm not worse just 93 for instance he's
suffering from this week porn on c6 I i
simply i can he can retreat in it this
is a kind of funny way to to draw yeah
it's probably around equal i spent too
much time i thought i should be somewhat
better here maybe I am uh yeah kinda
here can go F form maybe yeah I should
have maybe done that the problem is I
was always worried about this move but I
have had this response and I never
considered the head yeah this wasn't it
wasn't great yeah yeah this is sometimes
it happens that you that you somehow
recognize that your position is good and
you simply for whatever reason at least
this happens to me you don't spot the
move that really proves that you have
the advantages f4 f4 win cm simply and
you you fail to see this move on I don't
know have some misconception about this
and then you're kind of at least it
happens to me I'm sort of stuck and and
think forever like here because it's
he didn't make sense to me that I
shouldn't have a good plan because
everything's all right in fact now with
Bishop d7 black has repaired to quite
something about his structure and then I
was so so much down on time that i that
i blundered to to this because okay i
played this in one second and okay just
give me five seconds and I spot this
this f2 stuff yeah well thanks for
watching